[Music]  what can you tease for us about the next  episodes about the big three it's so I  can't even explain it and I don't always  say that but I don't there's so much  gonna be happening  excuse me I'm eight weeks pregnant  excited are you two going this baby  adventure with tape you know they've  only been together a year but like each  other that sounds right for them you  know and not everybody's story is the  same  bringing some understanding do things  eventually well a question you're  probably gonna get a lot now there's the  baby store airline is is it giving you  baby fever  okay here's the thing for many a year  okay nothing I'm also a huge family 7  News and of years I've plenty of  children in my family and I know but I  think the child chooses the parent and  so if that should happen ok but seeking  it's not I can't even keep a plant alive  no never home  [Music]  you